liquor line up the sponsors of this
segment want you to have a sweet
Thanksgiving let's head over to their
show to find out how
Welcome to our shop I'm Solomon we're
here with Mo what is the liquor lineup
for today today we're enjoying a sweet
tea bourbon cocktail something we can
enjoy while making or enjoying
Thanksgiving dinner first we start with
half ounce of simple syrup
two dashes of orange bitters
and then we add our highly allocated
bourbon an ounce and a half of our old
Forester
the liquor lineup specializes in limited
and allocated bottles go to our website
liquorlineup.com you can find this old
Forester and many other whiskeys and
Tequilas then finally we add about two
and a half ounces of iced tea
[Music]
we have all of these ingredients on our
app download our app liquor lineup and
you can get delivery
finally we garnish it with just a little
bit of lemon and a little bit of mint
spring delicious please enjoy
wow Mo that's strong very good enjoy
thank you liquor lineup for sponsoring
this segment for more information scan
that QR code right there on your screen
Jillian